voici xavier de verneuil à la campagne
et voici le même à la ville habillée en
tout nouveaux diplômés le premier est
agriculteur dans le sud de l'indre et
son alter ego urbain était en alternance
pendant 18 mois et étudiant à
l'université de paris dauphine
xavier vient d'obtenir une certification
gouvernance et stratégie coopérative à
l'issue d'une formation initiée et
financée par sa coopérative agricole
axéréal on voit très bien notamment par
rapport au marché des céréales
aujourd'hui qui est un marché mondialisé
et on a besoin d'avoir cette cette
connaissance ou en tout cas d'essayer de
décrypter ce qui se passe à l'étranger
et/ou en france d'ailleurs
mais autour du monde agricole pour
comprendre comment ils ce monde évolue
et prendre les bonnes décisions au jour
le jour sur les exploitations
à 35 ans est à la tête d'une
exploitation de 170 hectares de cultures
céréalières dans le boischaut sud
c'est-à-dire à 30 km au sud de
châteauroux
xavier de verneuil symbolise cette
nouvelle génération d'agriculteurs
connectés au monde une génération qui a
vocation à prendre deux mains les rênes
de sa coopérative ces jeunes ils vont
partir du territoire daksi real pouvoir
réfléchir à ce que sera la coopérative
de demain qui sera une coopérative qui
sera beaucoup plus tournés jeudi vers
ces notions de transition écologique de
décarbonation parle beaucoup de
biodiversité mais tout en produisant de
la quantité et de la qualité qualité
sanitaire une deuxième promotion
s'apprête à suivre le même chemin s'ils
sont dans le futur élu administrateur
d'accès real ils pèseront sur les
décisions d'une entreprise regroupant
près de 13000 agriculteurs en france et
dont les produits sont exportés dans 120
pays